have you heard about this poses at
funerals dead bodies imposes
at your own this is the new Big paying a
but don't take my word for it
with the media the life of the party
even though she's dead
friends at New Orleans socialite making
Easterling
through their power grand old funeral
down in the by you
not one stone was left unturned she
looks
to the like sitting in a garden
machinery
depict
contact your heart the eighty
three-year-old daughter said her mom
loves the limelight
love the attention so there she was
kinda posed with the help with some
extreme
embalming yet there she is I mean she
look
stuffed in taxidermy and all that good
stuff but he didn't get enough to a view
this we got two pictures and other
people that I had
been putting poses post posthumously for
the dead guy is the guy in the hoodie
that might be a sunglasses for a little
unclear to me for a second and the
people on the right if his wife and his
girlfriend
I'll rather get in return for more than
welcome back
weather is next in line look at this guy
her
is he having fun in death there why
wondering did he die on the spot
no because that's a little right now got
a pretty like hell but he's wearing
their
that would happen yeah I was wearing a
helmet has ended her mother I say go for
more of that kind of stuff yeah I should
be everything everything that was the
moment before your diet you should be
pros hey you know
yousef I calling it the diagram above
death
yeah I'm yes see i think you old museum
love these things yeah it's already four
yeah but such a move would pursue that
the guy claim in the good yeah
I are the people fucking I did yeah
grabbers web chat what about you
baseball bat hitting the guy doing the
aura
or II KN yet that term before you could
do a conic 10 like johnny carson doing
his golf swing
yeah it might get of course I wanted to
be
thrown out a helicopter just left
wherever he landed yeah I'm guessing you
are a good fit as my daughter
yeah I decided to go I see what pose
when I choose yeah it really don't have
to so that was my last question what
would you choose
here it is the for has I
other for over okay okay right here
camera your debt
both feel badly about a video on a
comment by
it I I never knew I had no idea you
a big question mark about a year ago
always always
from missing this actually seems kinda
cool to me why we don't talk about death
or out we'd all
Khalil a nice or debt that the video it
was a celebration of this woman's like
they had are doing the things that she
loved
yes it's a little weird I suppose but
but other cultures I mean you know you
go to you go to India and
you nope people are carrying the dead
body down to the gun geez and
burning the body is right there but it's
an event to family comes it
it's a celebration it's a you know
they're they're connected with
with it I think it's I think it's a guy
I think it's a step in the right
direction I really
yeah yeah Irish
yeah absolutely Irish know that I awake
oh yeah
they have a party it's a party we talk
about all that funny fun stuff the purse
and it's the kind of come alive
yeah stories and that had drunk and I
was lives on anywhere I love the
socialite I love it
and she guessed arrange the whole thing
and had ideas knew what she wanted in
yeah you know colonia how soon until we
do a little animatronics with these
people to
that's the the next essay right watch
out for the freaky guy that wanted the
love doll
yeah a lot of Congo I
knock it off yeah knock it off but
but I'll do we need to discuss that more
in this is it. we've talked about a
little bit on your show and i've done
your show and I feel like it is
something that we don't have a real
sort of healing discussion well I think
it underlies a lot of
what drives us in this country are our
consumerism is driven by our fear death
you know we don't have a quiet moment we
don't know how to sit still and not be
putting something either in our eyeballs
or mouth you know and
and thats that is appeared up that's the
underlying you know denial
love that that great monster always
around the corner the
the great unknown the biggest unknown
bring us are sick you must give me
something deep
that the science is now
projecting that a person can live and
the next
happen this century the wealthy should
be able to get the
Noel easy a machine to keep them alive
for a hundred and fifty years
exhaust have you heard about that seems
a bit by a hundred and fifty years 01
that let me guess bring time share
pretty
broken sure well of talk and flower
I 150
god damn spurring time American Idol
89 yeah I
jaylee I was ready to be killed after
American I
to bring them back to you